Hey Thoughty2 here.
Of all the planets that I’ve lived on, I’d
have to say Earth is probably my favorite.
And despite our best efforts to ruin it, it
still has some pretty spectacular features
like the jungles of the Amazon, the incredible
mountain ranges that litter the Earth’s
crust, the Great Lakes of northern America
and that Chinese takeaway on West street,
you know, the one with the free prawn crackers.
The thing is, us humans are a picky bunch
and we’re never quite happy with the way
things are.
There are phones to upgrade, windows to repaint,
houses to extend and suspicious pills to buy
from your junk email folder.
But what about the planet itself?
Can we fix any of those little issues that
have been bugging us for years like how the
Sahara is a bit too hot, Australia is definitely
too far away and can I just have a bit of
Greenland as I really don’t think anyone
it using it.
So grab a paint brush and let’s see if its
possible to change the planet to suit our
needs.
Can we edit Earth?
Back in the day, the land was all one big
lump, a supercontinent called Pangea.
But the shifting plates have really made a
mess of things since then, which is why you
can’t cycle from Melbourne to London anymore.
One thing we would like is for the ocean current
to once again flow mostly uninterrupted around
the equator.
We believe this could act to stabilize the
global climate, which, if you haven’t heard,
is doing about as well as global politics.
Right now, the Americas are sort of in the
way when it comes to having connected oceans
so we’re going to have to cut through it.
The idea is to supersize the Panama Canal
to the point where it’s more canal, less
Panama, basically removing the entire country,
much to the annoyance of Panamanians and hat
lovers across the world.
It would have to be done by a series of underground
nuclear explosions, or we could just use a
huge pile of Samsung Galaxys.
The original canal took about 30 years and
25,000 lives, displacing enough earth to build
a great wall of china from New York to San
Fransisco, and no one in their right mind
would want a wall all the way across America.
The US actually spent close to a $1 billion
in the 50s and 60s on Project Ploughshare,
looking at the feasibility of using nuclear
weapons as part of large scale engineering
projects such as accessing oil, building artificial
harbours and getting rid of entire countries
to link two oceans together, apparently.
There’s a fair bit of negotiating to be
done to make this happen and there’s no
scientific consensus on the outcome, with
some arguing that nuking the Isthmus of Panama
would actually hasten the loss of the Greenland
ice sheet, instead of slowing it down, which
is probably not ideal.
Northern Africa could do with some fresh water
and the nearest river is the Congo.
Unfortunately, getting access involves working
in a region that is still recovering from
a civil war that killed 4 million, so unless
you’re planning on tiptoeing in with a water
bottle, probably best to look somewhere else.
And, if fresh water is what you want, why
not take it from the most abundant source;
the Amazon.
Heinrich Hemmer suggested building a 4,300
kilometer pipe that would pick up fresh water
from the Amazons river’s mouth.
Romanian Physicist Viorel Badescu proposed
a pipe submerged 100m under the surface, anchored
to the sea floor.
It would be 30m wide and have 20 pumping stations
to keep the flow going, providing Northern
Africa with fresh water, as well as a number
of piranhas.
Of course, water doesn’t just come from
the ground; it also comes from the sky, roughly
every 18 minutes here in England, on a good
summer day.
But what if you could do with a bit more of
it?
You could try praying to Lono, Hawaiian god
of rain, but since he’s also in charge of
peace, music and sweet potatoes, I doubt you’ll
get an answer.
Dubai are taking matters into their own hands
with a plan to build a mountain.
The purpose is to force air to rise, thereby
creating more clouds.
They already have a number of successful cloud-seeding
projects but they are hoping to find a more
effective solution before all the ground water
is used up washing Lamborghinis with horrifically
ostentatious paint jobs.
The width and height of the mountain are still
being decided and then they can work out how
much it will cost, but it looks like it will
be almost half a trillion dollars.
Although, in other words, the average monthly
salary in Dubai.
Dubai is already pretty experienced at giving
itself plastic surgery though, since it has
been creating man-made islands for over 15
years.
The world’s second largest man-made island
is Yas and it’s due to be completed in 2018.
It will be used to create many schools and
hospit…
no I’m joking, this is Dubai, it’s covered
in Hotels and a Ferrari World theme park.
The various island projects started because
the city didn’t have enough beach and they
knew they had to grow tourism to the city
for when the oil eventually runs out.
The first major project was Palm Island, which
was designed to fit a long length of beach
in a compact space.
First of all, they needed to dredge almost
10 million cubic meters of sand from a nearby
bay and they used this, along with millions
of tonnes of quarried rock, in a range of
sizes including huge 6 ton blocks, to create
the land.
They couldn’t have done it without the help
of the world’s greatest land reclaimers;
the Dutch, who consulted on the project.
Flevopolder, near Amsterdam, is the largest
man-made island; 970 km2 of land stolen right
back out the sea.
One Dutch Geochemist called Roelof Schuiling
had maybe the grandest idea of all, once again
in the Middle East.
At the Strait of Hormuz, where the Gulf Sea
connects with the Indian Ocean, the water
is just 39 kilometers across.
Schuiling’s idea was to dam the whole thing,
once the oil trade dies out because right
now there are quite a lot of tankers using
it and a dam would make them very late for
work.
Once the dam was in place, the water on one
side would become lower than the other, thanks
to the process of evaporation.
You could then use this difference to generate
an enormous amount of hydro-electric power,
about 2,500 megawatts in this case, which
would power almost two million homes.
Unfortunately, without the exchange with the
Indian Ocean, the Gulf would get saltier and
saltier so you’d probably kill all the sea
life.
So, dolphins, you’ve got about 20 years
to start producing electricity or you’ve
got it coming.
Maybe start farming electric eels or just
give us back all the oil the BP have so generously
been donating to you over the years, you don’t
even drive; you selfish water mammals.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.